I'm Nelson Dallas five-time USA memory
champion and memory coach and today
we're going to be answering your
questions on Twitter this is memory
support
[Music]
at gulab zamman asks does lack of sleep
affect memory yes definitely if you
don't get enough sleep you're not going
to be able to pay attention or have
tremendous Focus the next day and focus
is a huge Cornerstone of having a good
memory on the other side of things sleep
is super important for consolidating
memories During certain deeper states of
sleep your hippocampus is actually
transferring data from short term to the
long term and if that process doesn't
happen you will potentially lose that
information so it's a way to consolidate
that day's information for the long term
at Joe guy 358 asks does memory loss or
weakening always mean Dementia or
Alzheimer's definitely not although I
will say if you are worried I would
consult a doctor just because you're
getting older doesn't mean that your
memory has to get worse my family has a
history of Alzheimer's My Grandmother
Had Alzheimer's and that's actually what
spurred this journey for me into the
world of mnemonics I didn't have a good
memory before I learned about memory
technique weeks of memory championships
and it all started because seeing my
grandmother passed away made me question
you know is that my future the
encouraging message here is that we all
can improve our memories so if you feel
like you have a bad memory or you're
worried that your memory is aging you
can turn it around at Bobby meow asks
how the [ __ ] can someone solve a Rubik's
cube blindfolded so what people will do
is they'll assign each of the pieces a
letter of the alphabet so technically
each part of each piece has its own
letter so the top here might be an a
whereas the back here might be a Q and
if you can remember the sequence in
which the pieces need to be solved you
can create a sequence of letters which
could equate to a series of words at
Barnaby farn asks how the actual [ __ ]
does memory work so it used to be
thought that memories were stored
entirely in the hippocampus which is a
part of the brain parallel to your ear
about the size of your thumb recently
they discovered that it's actually
different kinds of memories are stored
in different parts of the brain at
orbital railgun asks what the [ __ ] is it
about moving that totally wipes my
memory I get up to do something and I
instantly forget what that thing was so
it's there's an interesting study that
was done by a psychologists at Notre
Dame where he talked about this
phenomenon that we forget things when we
move through doorways when you open the
fridge and you forget what you opened it
for or you walk into a room and you
forget what you were walking in there
for we forget things where we cross an
event boundary and so there wasn't
really any solution to it other than
maybe when you're trying to memorize
something stay where you are rather than
Crossing some kind of barrier mid
learning or mid-memory I not casually
cruel me asks how the [ __ ] I can
memorize Taylor Swift lyrics but not
physics formulas there are a few things
at play here one is procedural memory
that's basically muscle memory when you
sing a song or listen to a song over and
over again you are building it into your
long-term muscle memory second at play
here is the emotional response you know
you're connecting to her music her
lyrics the way it makes you feel and
that's a lot more interesting than say a
physics formula and then the third thing
at play is encoding the way that the
song is structured the beat the Rhythm
the way things rhyme lends itself to
being easier to memorize that hashtag
life Greg asks got any hacks for how to
remember a list of 11 items let's say
you want to remember a list of grocery
items all right let's say that we have
asparagus bread bananas sour cream and
coffee beans to memorize that list we
can use a technique called the linking
method which basically takes each of the
items on our list turns them into some
kind of fun interactive image and
connects it one by one to the next one
in the list so maybe this is how we
picture it right we have asparagus so
maybe I take those asparagus Spears and
stab the bread and break it down into
pieces and it reveals that there was a
banana inside I then peel that banana
and maybe some sour cream liquid just
pours out of it right and then finally
maybe I scoop up that sour cream and
just dump it in my coffee which is
filled with coffee beans so that list
would be asparagus bread bananas sour
cream and coffee beans and what we've
done is each of those individual images
has a element of a story that can
connects it or links it to the next
thing in the list at JJ Pierce asks how
do you memorize lines overnight asking
for a friend yeah so there's this
technique I called the first letter
method and basically you take a passage
that you're trying to memorize and you
read it a few times then write it down
this is important just the first letters
of each word as they show themselves in
the actual text then you'll be surprised
that you can actually read from that
first letter only script and remember
the full words for the whole thing you
do that a few times then take it away
close your eyes and see if you can
remember it and most times like nine
times out of ten you'll have the whole
passage memorized at orcana h j asks is
there a correlation between exercise and
memory yes both indirectly and directly
indirectly you know being fit and
working on exercising makes you feel
good it lowers anxiety reduces stress
improves sleep all of those things
improve your memory and then directly it
improves blood flow to the brain it
reduces inflammation in the brain and it
encourages brain health Alex Fran disco
asks what is a Memory Palace and how do
you make one inquiring minds want to
know all right so Memory Palace it's a
technique where you use a physical space
that you map out in your mind and you
place images for the things you're
memorizing along that pathway some of
the best memory palaces are going to be
places that you're super familiar with
and then when you want to recall the
information all you got to do is go back
to that same physical space in your mind
and walk through the place so let's say
that you wanted to memorize the five
largest countries in the world in order
those happen to be Russia Canada USA
China and Brazil since we're doing this
together maybe we could use this table
now our pathway that we're going to
decide on is going to start at the brain
and make its way to this side of the
table to the headphones one image per
location now in terms of what are we
putting on each location well with
countries you can maybe think of an
association that's natural to you for
example for Russia I might think of a
martini Avant called Martini so I would
imagine maybe on the brain is a balanced
martini glass filled with vodka then I
go to the next location I'm on the
laptop we have to memorize Canada I
think of Canada I think of a hockey
stick they play a lot of hockey right so
maybe a hockey stick is just slap
shotting the crap out of this thing and
sending it flying into the wall and
exploding into bits next one would be
the third location the deck of cards an
association for USA I might think of
like a hamburger so maybe I would
imagine instead of an actual burger
patty in my bun but it's a deck of cards
stuck in there next we go to the fourth
location and that would be the fourth
thing that I'm trying to memorize which
is China I think of chopsticks for
Chinese food so I'd have to incorporate
that image with this object so I'd
imagine maybe picking this up with
chopsticks and having a hard time kind
of rotating the cube trying to solve it
and then finally the last location here
would be our Brazil I think of Brazil I
think of soccer ball they play soccer
really well so I would maybe imagine
putting these headphones around a soccer
ball so you can listen to some jams now
we've just just memorize the list
doesn't really feel like it but if we
wanted to remember the list and recall
it we just go back through our little
Memory Palace and pull up the images
that we left there Martini Russia hockey
stick Canada Burger USA Chopsticks China
soccer ball Brazil what's kind of
beautiful about this technique is that
you can say that list now forwards or
you could say it backwards or you could
just jump to any location and get any
piece of information as you wanted at
ABDO Viper asks how to memorize a deck
of cards at the memory championships one
of the events is to memorize a full 52
card deck in sequence as fast as
possible now the way I do that I do a
combination of changing the Cards into
images and then storing them in a Memory
Palace how do I come up with the images
there's a system called the Pao system
person action object every card I've
given a preset person action and object
to so whenever I see it I don't see the
call hard I see the person or the action
associated with that or the object and
for every three cards I group them into
this mini scene the first card's always
the person the second card's always the
action or the verb and the third is the
object so to take an example the first
card that we had was eight of clubs
which to me is Bear Grylls the action
Adventurer guy I probably can't even
remember why it became that but there
was a reason whenever I see eight of
clubs it's Bear Grylls it feels like I'm
looking at them it's so ingrained then
this next card is the second in a
sequence of three so it's the action and
my action for four of Hearts is
urinating so we have Bear Grylls
urinating and then the third card in
this set Ace of clubs is a thong that's
my image for it so I have Bear Grylls
urinating on a thumb weird but memorable
uh and I place it in one of my memory
palaces the first location of which is
my high school bedroom I imagine that
action that little story happening in a
location at a Memory Palace then we go
into the next location essentially it's
a person action and then an object and
then do that for every subsequent set of
three and I move through my memory
Palace as I place down those different
sets of images and then I continue that
process for every subsequent set of
three until there's no more cards left
seven of diamonds uh King of Spades two
of spades Ace of Spades three of Spades
you get the idea at tanvi Agarwal asks
how are bad memories so so clear and
exact in our minds but happy memories
Fade Away back in the Medieval ages they
would throw kids in the river after
memorizing something and it was so that
they could actually remember the
information better because their
adrenaline spiked right after learning
and there are studies that show that in
situations of high stress or where your
adrenaline is peaked you're actually
going to remember that information
better at summer arens asks how does
memory have fragrance like why can I
summon the smell of fall 2019 into my
brain explain how I can smell my
kindergarten classroom but I don't know
what I did yesterday so smell is one of
the earliest evolved senses in our brain
and it actually bypasses this thing
called the thalamus which is responsible
for kind of delegating information
between different parts of the brain so
technically with smell memories they go
directly to either the amygdala or the
hippocampus which are responsible for
dealing with memories that's why usually
smell memories are so intense and so
instant at everyday innov TR R asks
anyone ever competed in the United
States memory championship
yes many times the five-time USA memory
Champion winner this is actually the
trophy that I got from my most recent
win last year it's in the shape of the
seahorse which is what the hippocampus
looks like the competition is pretty
interesting in itself it's a day-long
event where we basically memorize
useless stuff decks of playing cards
huge phone numbers lists of words names
and faces poetry and more and basically
whoever can memorize the most the
fastest and the most accurately becomes
the USA memory champion at yours not
truly asks how do you remember passwords
are you mind mapping like homes first of
all a password has to be memorable but
it also needs to be secure one of the
best ways to do it is to choose a
sentence that is funny or weird or
bizarre to you
Nelson Charles that's my middle name
Dallas
rocks my socks off take that sentence
and just break it down into the first
letters capital n capital c capital D
lowercase r m s o exclamation keep
things that were Capital keep things
that were lowercase and there you have a
pretty complex password it's not my
actual password by the way at above oh
add Mala asks how are mnemonics helpful
it's just a second thing to memorize
when you use mnemonics and the proper
technique you're taking advantage of
things that our brains are really good
at namely thinking in pictures we
remember pictures way better than
anything else pictures that have meaning
to yourself and then secondly spatial
orientation or organization how do you
structure the images or things that
you're memorizing if you have a way to
do that you're making your life much
easier at Charlie weather asks how do
you remember people's names really tired
of feeling like I'm disrespecting
everyone I meet all the time this is
probably one of the most common
questions I get it's only normal that
when we're meeting people we're probably
thinking about the smart thing we want
to say or looking cool but we're not
paying attention to the person in front
of us who's about to tell us their name
but there is a technique and I actually
am pretty good at this this is one of
the records that I still hold so let's
do an example I've been given 25
different faces here all hiding a name
behind the photo and I'm going to take a
minute or two to look this over and
memorize them first you turn the name
into a picture I would look at the
person's face find something quick about
them that I noticed usually the first
thing that comes to mind whether it's
pretty eyes a distinctive mole a big red
beard so for this guy Oliver I think of
Oliver Twist so I thought of me twisting
his beard pretty forcefully he doesn't
look too pleased about it in his
expression there so it kind of makes the
image a little more funny then I just
repeated that process through all 25
names I did a quick review just to make
sure that I had it solidified okay so
that took me about a minute or two and
let's see if I can get them all right so
this guy is Max
this girl is Georgia
Sandy
Virginia
Stan
Tara
Lucas
Todd
William
Sean
uh Alma
Akash
um Camila
Sophia
Emma
Sarah
Elijah
Carmella
Eric
uh Carla yep uh Keith
Noah
Mara
Cindy and Oliver
there we go
foreign
asks what is your favorite resource for
training your memory for tests and
quizzes there really are three ways to
get something into your long-term memory
one is spaced repetition so spacing out
over time the things the study sessions
basically what you're trying to memorize
give it some room so cramming is not a
good idea the second thing is
interleaving so in between sessions you
actually study something totally
different and then come back to the
information you're trying to remember
that's also very effective third would
be active recall so actually trying
actively to remember the things that
you're trying to remember that sounds
pretty obvious but you'd be surprised
how many people just look at the thing
they're memorizing and think that
they'll have it in their memory just by
going through it over and over again
when you put that thing away and you
just close your eyes and you really try
to get it even if it's not perfect that
process is so effective at afro Diddy
asks anyone know foods that improve your
memory yeah there's a few avocado
blueberries broccoli turmeric dark
chocolate and walnuts I think the main
one that I would encourage people to
investigate is omega-3 DHA specifically
it's a fatty acid found in the brain we
don't get a lot of it in our diet but we
need it to help improve our brain health
so you can get that from fish oil pills
there are certain foods that have it
like fatty fish like salmon at bipolar
bear dick says Prevagen says it'll help
your memory because it contains
jellyfish do jellyfish have good
memories I don't know specifically about
Prevagen but there's a lot of kind of
snake oil type brain supplements out
there often they're referred to as
nootropics some don't really have any
proof or the research is very weak or
not proven the best pill you can take to
improve your memory is not a pill at all
it's just better diet better sleep more
exercise and using your memory so those
are all the questions for today I hope I
inspired you a little bit to start your
journey into the world of memory thanks
for watching memory support